alexander dugan to russian nationalists
he's a philosopher and strategist who
represents president vladimir putin's
policies
to his critics he is a pro-kremlin
fascist who has openly called for the
killing of ukrainians the first
the likely target of a car bombing near
moscow late saturday
dugan was saved by a last-minute vehicle
change as he left a cultural event
his daughter daria dugina took his place
and the bomb that was probably meant for
him
dugan was filmed looking on powerless to
do anything the car carrying his
daughter still in flames
at the moment investigators and forensic
specialists of the main investigative
directorate of the russian investigative
committee for the moscow region together
with the colleagues from the main
forensic department of the russian
investigative committee and the bomb
experts continue working on the crime
scene
29 year old daria duguino was a russian
broadcaster and political commentator
both father and daughter expressed
far-right nationalist views strongly
supported the invasion of ukraine and
were placed on international sanctions
lists for spreading misinformation
we do not know who has carried out the
attack
the ukrainians have fiercely denied it
although the russians have of course
blamed them including allies of dugans
and no matter what the sort of you know
real story is the kremlin will use this
uh to double down its rhetoric on
ukraine we've seen the kremlin respond
in that way to almost every incident now
ukraine has said it does not resort to
terror tactics blaming russia's own
government or security apparatus
a picture of russian nationalism the
public face of what many view as putin's
expansionist policies
even referred to as putin's brain
dugan's views likely marked him for
death
his attackers whoever they are
got his daughter instead
zain basravi al-jazeera
alexander dugan is a russian philosopher
political analyst and strategist he was
the chief editor at the pro-kremlin
sargrad tv station
dugan has helped shape vladimir putin's
expansionist foreign policies and has
been called putin's brain
he was involved in the russian
president's initiative for the
annexation of crimea and considered the
invasion of ukraine inevitable
dugan has previously called for the
eradication of ukrainian identity
let's bring in dimitri babich he's a
political analyst at inosumi which is a
russian state-owned media company that
monitors western media he joins us now
from moscow thank you very much for your
time
uh sir do you think that the real target
was alexander dugan are we taking that
as as the likeliest scenario
uh it's hard to say now most of the
analysts here say he was the target
but i am not sure because uh daria was
becoming a media figure of her role
and uh she was actually more popular
than her father at the moment of her
death okay i wouldn't call mr jojen
putin's brain it's certainly not true
you know
i don't agree with dugan's views which i
consider very strange and radical
but
he certainly
had not been a member of putin's
administration for many years and he was
ousted from sagrad and the fulsargra tv
and from the moscow state university
where he was
a professor so in the last few years he
was on his own and uh he was vocal uh
but if we talk about his friends i would
say that uh mr zielenski's aide alexei
aristovich was much closer to dogen than
putin during several years uh just uh a
decade ago
so uh dugan to my mind is a very shady
figure and i would not connect him
directly to putin okay uh but this
murder was certainly targeted it was
certainly attacked in russian
nationalism that's absolutely true i
mean dugan previously had called for the
eradication of ukrainian identity so no
doubt views like that are gonna going to
garner him a lot of of critics who do
you think was behind this what evidence
is there right now
well i think this phrase is taken out of
context as i tell you as i told you i
don't agree with putin and i can see his
views too radical
but please note that he never talked
about killing ukrainians or destroying
ukrainian nations he just said that
modern ukraine was a pro-western
state
very much
hostile to russia he said that the
coming to power of uh the so-called
maidan
uh insurgency you know when uh 38
policemen were killed in 2014 was not
democratic it was bad and here i agree
with him
uh as for who was behind his murder uh i
would not listen to the ukrainian
versions because they're just absurd you
know they say that russians killed dugan
themselves so that they could attack uh
ukraine's celebrations of its
independence on their 24th of august
that's certainly absurd
unfortunately in the last few years we
have seen several prominent figures of
russian nationalists seen
murdered
by bombs uh you know murdered by uh
in very brutal violent ways
uh it's clear to my mind uh that
someone who wants to provoke uh
provoke uh further conflict between
russia and ukraine is behind it because
certainly mr duggan is going to become a
a marcher figure as uh the father or or
his murdered daughter is going to become
a martyr figure in in the eyes of many
uh that will not make him exempt from
from criticism in russia a lot of people
criticized uh logan in russia publicly
uh but his daughter you know i knew her
and we were on television several times
together
she was a very nice person beautiful
kind girl unfortunately she was almost
indistinguishable from her father in her
political clues
but we all hope that would change
unfortunately her death makes it
impossible now i mean
yeah we're saying we're talking about
who is responsible whoever was
responsible if uh alexander dugan was in
fact the target then this wasn't exactly
a successful
uh assassination i guess you would call
it is it i mean what does that suggest
to you that perhaps it wasn't uh quite
so professional or
what does that say to you
well
i think it's very possible that the
murderers were targeting daria and not
her father
she was
prominent she was beautiful she was
outspoken she was very kind
she
was the end on several popular
television and radio shows so i would
not exclude the possibility that she was
the target if he was the type
then i would not call the people who
killed him anti-fascist
dugan was what my friend uh prophecy
gold goldhagen called a hideous model
hat
his views are very very strange and
sometimes absurd but they are not the
mainstream views in russia
so uh
i i think uh that basically in the last
few years uh
dugan was more or less harmless because
okay he published books that a few
thousands of people read he was kind of
a cult figure uh in his own small
group called durations you know
but
he did not make any impact on politics
certainly it would be wrong to say that
he was the putin's brain or the person
behind putin's policies this is all
simply not true there are too many facts
speaking against it
but the person who killed here who
killed daria and who probably wanted to
kill putin to my mind that person is not
an anti-fascist this is obviously a
terrorist act which will have a very
negative impact because it will make the
war between russia and ukraine much
bloodier and much more violent
because uh you know she was loved by
many and uh mr duggan himself had his
own limited but very devoted uh circle
of uh supporters all right we'll leave
it there i think we have to leave it
there i'm sorry for time
i hear what you're saying thank you very
much for your time dimitri babich there
a political analyst joining us from
moscow we appreciate it